en 1963
trajo al mundo esta escena ahora de
culto simbolizando su estilo radical y
provocador
tres años antes de su primer
largometraje sin aliento rompió las
reglas cinematográficas de la época
estableciendo la estética visual del
movimiento de la 'nouvelle vague'
gracias a la revisión técnica a las
cámaras son más pequeñas
[Música]
kodak salió a grabar fuera de los
estudios y llevó la vida real y la
modernidad al cine
es una película que se hizo como una
reacción contra todo lo que no se hacía
casi sistemáticamente hemático palou
blow de casino es un primer plano con un
objetivo amplio entonces hagámoslo
charlín gama bondad al ser y para mí
esto se correspondía con el deseo de
mostrar que todo estaba permitido de
monje que tú te perdí nació en parís en
1930 y se crió en suiza en una familia
acomodada un personaje enigmático en la
línea de sus en los años 70 agudas que
participó activamente en la revuelta
estudiantil de mayo del 68 se embarcó en
un cine más político antes de encontrar
de nuevo el éxito en los años 80 a lo
largo de su carrera al cineasta nunca
dejó de cuestionar los límites del
séptimo arte con innovaciones que la
crítica no siempre recibió bien mi curso
de jefe decir un códice películas que
muchos otros no se atrevieron a hacer
para el 11 y elohim el espectáculo
respetaban y también me odiaban por él y
además a poggi chelsea acordes o en 2018
sanidad ganó una palma de oro especial
en el festival de cannes por el libro de
las imágenes y en 2010 recibió un oscar
en honor a toda su carrera coronando a
un cineasta que rompió el libro de
reglas diciéndole al mundo que el cine
podía hacer lo que uno quisiera no hay
diferencia entre el cine y la vida